a
[Música]
hola soy aleida macará leioa chévez y al
igual que muchos de ustedes mi infancia
transcurrió jugando con mis amigos si
esos juegos tradicionales como los yaks
como el trompo salíamos ya sea a la
calle a un parque y disfrutábamos de
alguna aventura algún deporte sin
embargo esto cambió cuando cumplí 6 años
de edad en aquel momento fui
diagnosticada con artritis reumatoidea
juvenil una enfermedad que hasta hoy día
no tiene cura y que cambió todo mi
estilo de vida por completo esta
enfermedad consiste en la inflamación de
las articulaciones y generar mucho dolor
a la edad de los 6 años esto fue muy
duro para mí cambio incluso mi rutina de
aprendizaje y me llevó a estar en cama
por largos periodos sin embargo pude
continuar mis estudios y cuando terminé
la secundaria no dude en cuál sería
el ejido es así que postulé a la
universidad en la carrera de educación e
hice mis cinco años de estudios
universitarios
durante el periodo recibí mucho apoyo de
mis maestros no me puedo quejar se
comprometieron para mejorar mis
aprendizajes para que yo pudiera
descubrir la importancia que tiene la
educación en cómo desarrollar el proceso
de aprendizaje y cómo motivar a mis
estudiantes sin embargo esto cambió un
poco
o se separó de aquellas ideas del juego
y de la aventura cuando ingresé fui
bastante joven y al entrar por primera
vez a un aula me encontré con
estudiantes de quinto de secundaria de
aproximadamente 17 años de edad algunos
eran muy altos e incluso me llevaban más
de 20 centímetros de altura no les puedo
negar la verdad es que estuve muy
nerviosa y al entrar a medio año a una
institución educativa yo suponía un reto
mucho mayor
es ahí donde empiezo a preguntarme cómo
puedo hacer para captar la atención de
mis estudiantes cómo puedo hacer para
motivarlos para que logren los
aprendizajes que ellos necesitan es allí
a donde recuerdo las aventuras que tuve
en mi infancia si ya no fueron aventuras
en los cuales podía correr en las cuales
podría practicar algún deporte sino
aventuras en donde podía volar con la
imaginación en donde podía descubrir un
nuevo escenario o una nueva historia y
ser la protagonista aunque en la vida
real no pudiera correr y no pudiera
jugar con mis amigos es a donde voy
tomando estas ideas para aplicarlas en
el proceso educativo y que mis
estudiantes tuvieran diversas
oportunidades de vivir aventuras hoy en
día solemos pensar en la educación como
aquella que va a preparar a los niños y
niñas para el futuro pero sin embargo
que tanto de ese futuro les acercamos a
ellos en
permitimos que ellos puedan vivir estas
aventuras que es ahí a donde voy
conociendo una metodología llamada
gamificación la gamificación consiste en
tomar elementos del juego y unirlos a
procesos que no son lúdicos en este caso
al proceso educativo
en realidad la gamificación no surge en
el ámbito educativo surge en el ámbito
empresarial pero la educación aprende de
todos partes y es ahí a donde toma estas
ideas para unirlas al proceso de
aprendizaje y así motivar a los
estudiantes tal vez esté sonando un poco
abstracto todo esto que comparto así que
qué tal si lo vemos mediante un ejemplo
mis estudiantes pueden vivir diversas
aventuras si bien es cierto no son
arquitectos no son científicos o
diseñadores de moda
mediante la gamificación la educación se
presenta como un escenario en el cual
pueden ser científicos diseñadores de
moda o arquitectos al menos por un
tiempo es así que hemos desarrollado
diferentes proyectos en uno de estos
proyectos los estudiantes diseñaron una
colección de moda juvenil basada en la
iconografía de nuestros ancestros
incluso llegamos a desarrollar una
pasarela en donde los estudiantes fueron
los modelos que desfilaron fue un día de
mucha emoción a donde lo compartimos con
toda la comunidad educativa pues se
estaba presentando esta es nueva
experiencia de ser diseñadores de moda
de ser modelos y de ser empresarios pues
esto se presentaba como un
emprendimiento al final subastamos las
prendas que habían sido diseñados y las
experiencias de aprendizaje y la emoción
vivida es uno de los mejores recuerdos
que ellos pueden tener de hecho algunos
de los estudiantes que participaron en
este proyecto hoy se encuentran
estudiando la carrera de diseño de moda
de manera profesional otro aspecto que
debemos comprender es cómo estamos
afectando a nuestro ambiente el cambio
climático es innegable pero nos cuesta
muchas veces descubrirnos como actores
de ese cambio climático es por ello que
desarrollamos el proyecto de calculadora
de dióxido de carbono los estudiantes
mediante el lenguaje de programación
diseñaron esta calculadora que nos
permite conocer cuánto dióxido de
carbono estamos generando ya sea por ver
televisión por emplear un celular o
emplear el microondas una vez que nos
damos cuenta de cuál es nuestra huella
de carbono podemos tomar decisiones para
mitigar la es por eso que la calculadora
además no se enfrenta a una realidad
cuántos árboles
tendríamos que plantar para conseguir
mitigar el daño que estamos generando al
ambiente como vemos la gamificación nos
ofrece esta posibilidad de generar en la
escuela un escenario de aprendizaje en
el cual podemos vivir una aventura
desempeñando diferentes roles siendo los
héroes y las heroínas de ese proceso
pero a la vez siendo los héroes y
heroínas de una sociedad de una
comunidad que nos requiere
lamentablemente el proceso educativo en
la actualidad no siempre está orientado
al autodescubrimiento se orienta al
desarrollo de competencias a cumplir con
un currículo de aprendizaje pero no
siempre concebimos a la educación como
la oportunidad de auto descubrirnos como
personas de descubrirnos como agentes
activos de nuestra comunidad de
descubrirnos como los héroes y las
heroínas de nuestra sociedad
es por ello que la gamificación llega a
cambiar este aspecto de la educación ya
presentarnos una educación en la cual
divertirnos vivir una aventura y ser los
héroes es bueno porque nos ayuda a
conocernos y nos ayuda a construir la
sociedad que necesitamos y que merecemos
mediante la gamificación se han dado
muchas experiencias en mi aula de clase
y mis estudiantes han egresado
descubriendo quiénes son para su
comunidad quiénes pueden llegar a ser el
cambio que pueden generar en su entorno
además también debemos pensar en que la
gamificación ofrece oportunidades no
sólo dentro de las aulas el cotidiano
muchas veces nos retrae y pensamos que
ser adultos nos aleja de la oportunidad
de divertirnos y de vivir experiencias
pero pasará si vemos nuestra vida como
una experiencia en la cuales somos los
héroes y las heroínas de nuestra
historia
si nosotros concebimos a nuestra vida
como una oportunidad de vivir una
aventura y no como una carga estoy
segura que nuestra percepción de la vida
y nuestras tomas de decisiones serán
mucho mejores porque aceptaremos la
posibilidad de equivocarnos y
aceptaremos que con ese error podemos
mejorarnos a nosotros mismos creando
cambio en nuestro entorno creando un
cambio en nosotros mismos y
contribuyendo a la mejora de nuestra
comunidad hoy los invito a repensar en
nuestras vidas en repensar nuestro
proyecto de aprendizaje para que de esa
manera podamos descubrir nosotros que
nuestra vida es una experiencia de
aventura que nosotros somos los héroes
actores de esta aventura y que nosotros
podemos generar cambio en la vida de los
demás si nosotros comprendemos esto
aprenderemos a disfrutar cada situación
de nuestra vida aprenderemos a disfrutar
cada día de nuestra vida y
comprenderemos que equivocarnos es parte
del proceso y que si aprendemos
desarrollo podremos mejorar nosotros
mismos
[Música]